brought to you by far cry primal rise
above extinction in stores februari 23rd
hey guys my name is Jess it is the 18th
of every today and you're tuned into
games button 355 is currently letting
players Rach quiz matches without
penalty that seems like a massive
oversight but Capcom say they're
currently working on a fix since launch
plays you quit out of the match before
the game can send results to capcom
servers don't register a loss or a
victory you're a gamer discovered the
exploit and a Capcom spokesperson
replied i can confirm that it is
something we're going to be addressing
to make the gameplay experience one that
all fans can enjoy and be rewarded
fairly for your gamer have pointed out
that obviously the lack of a system
which penalizes rage quitters is a big
problem for ranked play because it
essentially allows players to prevent
themselves from falling down the ranks
next up Ubisoft has indicated that
Assassin's Creed will be moving off its
really release schedule the franchise
has had an annual major release every
year since the launch of assassin's
creed two that is until this year where
there will be no major elite Ubisoft CEO
is Guillermo said during a Ubisoft
Investor Day presentation the goal is
not automatically to come back on annual
cycle but to come on a regular basis
what we're seeing today is promising we
will be able to come on a regular basis
but we can't say every year later on in
the presentation CFO Allen Martinez
explains the priority is currently to
give the development team the time they
need to create the best possible games
and if they feel they're in a strong
position there is a possibility that
major AC games will come out every year
but it's not require
finally Bethesda has taste the projects
they're working on next speaking of this
year's dice summit flat floor director
todd howard said we have three longest
known projects that we're doing better
all well talk about them in a much
future date but they're different from
anything we've done before while also
being a bit as de style game big and
crazy how it also confirms a Bethesda's
recently established montreal studio is
working on mobile projects among other
undisclosed things if you're a fallout
for easter egg junkie you may also be
interested to know that Howard mentioned
there is a fallout 4 secret that is yet
to be discovered he wouldn't give much
away but did confirm it's related to a
terminal let me know down in that
comment section what you cared about
today and be sure to head to gamespot
we've got stories on even more dying
light DLC and free steak again that is
everything I have for you today back be
sure to join me same time tomorrow for
the top five stories of the entire week